Okay, so we have an official statement, um,
by the TV network that streams your vision here in the Netherlands.
And it reads like this.
An incident occurred after last Thursday's performance
against clearly made agreements.
Yost was filmed when he had just gotten off stage
and had to rush to the green room.
At that moment,
Yost repeatedly indicated that he did not want to be filmed.
This wasn't respected,
and this LED to a threatening movement from Yost towards the camera.
Yost did not touch the camera.
WOMAN this incident was reported,
followed by an investigation by the EBU and police.
Yesterday and today we consulted extensively, uh,
with the EBU and proposed several solutions.
Nevertheless, the EBU has still decided to disqualify yours client.
Abrotros, uh,
finds the penalty, uh,
very heavy and disproportionate.
We stand for good manners.
Let there be no misunderstanding about that.
But in our view,
an exclusion order is not proportional to this incident.
We are very disappointed and upset, uh,
for the millions of fans who were so excited for tonight.
What yours brought to the Netherlands and Europe
shouldn't have ended this way.
So here it is, you guys.
This is the official statement, uh,
done by the, um,
TV network the streams your vision here in the Netherlands.
Um, it's usually very much in line with the EBU.
But for them to come up with a statement like this
means that they really think that the decision by the EBU
to disqualify your client was disproportionate.
So you have it. Guys, I think it's just unfair.